speaking of brainwashing
i am going to show you the best moment i
have ever seen during interviews with
trump supporters and trump rally
attendees
there is a video of a little kid brought
to this weekend's trump rally in selma
north carolina
and the reporter asked the kid what are
you excited for
and the kid goes i'm excited to see joe
biden oh and the mom goes trump
trump
now i have a few thoughts about what
might be going on here listen closely to
what the mom says this is the best clip
from a trump rally i have ever seen how
excited were you when you found out
there was gonna be a rally here
i mean just as excited as he was he's
the one that told me about it so yeah
yeah
first rally too yes sir i think they're
more excited than we are
are you excited
what are you excited for
i'm the secret body
[Laughter]
oh that is genius so okay so did you
guys notice
uh how
the mom kept saying it's the kids who
told us about the rally it's the kids
who are really the excited ones it's
almost like they're trying to say it's
like when you go to disney world and
you're like look they wanted to come i
don't want to be here but they wanted to
come
but maybe the kids have no idea what's
going on i mean the kid seems to think
he's at a joe biden rally
so this could be one of these things
where they're pushing their desire to be
there on to the kids and the kids have
no interest and they're just being
dragged in
whatever it is
it is one of the most genius clips i
have ever seen from a trump event here
is another one this one seems like a
parody two brothers say a lot of really
wacky stuff
seems like every meeting i see
is undisgraceful
did you guys hear that
it's not disgraceful
it's
undisgraceful whoa whoa that's pretty
strong and we're ungodly and we support
you guys 100 percent 100
and we just and we just want to tell the
fake news cnn msnbc all y'all
y'all are disgraceful to this country
and we're going to come after you
demonic your devils we get saved right
are you guys brothers
yeah
so um if i told you guys that's a joke
that's the those are comedians and they
troll trump rallies that was satire who
would say no david that doesn't make
sense you would say that makes perfect
sense that makes more sense than that
these guys really exist as such here's
another guy at the trump rally saying
that january 6 was antifa
are we supposed to believe that they
didn't set up the protesters on january
6 right that's i mean that's exactly
right there's video out there that
they're trying to suppress it's all on
people's tick tocks and stuff where they
had antifa members inside the white
house on that day saying we need more
people we need more people are they now
why would there be antifa at the white
house when trump was president does that
does that make any sense
oh okay no so now the other guy corrects
him and goes do you mean the capital
right to the floor in one of the offices
a lady was in the window with a
megaphone
telling people what to do and where to
go
yeah there's so many holes in the
official narrative about january 6th
right it's just not none of it really
makes sense
and of course like why would antifa try
to
keep trump in office and prevent biden
from being sworn in they they never have
an answer to that and lastly here's a
couple guys who have spent 30 grand
going to trump rallies they cost you
guys to drive across the country i'm
just curious like how much of your own
money you know obviously your own money
that you've invested to do this so this
is my 45th trump rally i probably
invested 30 000 of my own money coming
here but by the way
invested
uh
not exactly financial literacy you know
you're really burning the money you're
not investing it i would look at index
funds uh and maybe a little bit of money
in a high-yield savings account if
you're actually looking for investments
i don't know that going to trump rallies
really counts as an investment i can
tell you in the last year it's
it's been worse it's been worse the
flights are double the rent-a-cars are
double gas is almost four dollars a
gallon all along the east coast it's
it's getting ridiculous you know i want
it back to we want it back to two dollar
gas we want it back to 100 flights and
we want it back to cheap rental cars
well i don't know if that's gonna happen
because things do get more expensive
over time but
any one of these
could be a joke any one of these could
be a skit
on saturday night live without a doubt
and it would be
it would be more funny
if this wasn't a political movement with
teeth
that
might get people as crazy as herschel
walker elected so that we've now looked
at the wacky from the weekend
but i am going to have to read everybody
the riot act i apologize in the next
segment
because uh as wacky as some of the
supporters are and as wacky as some of
the candidates are
some of them are leading in polls
and it is a dystopian
nightmare that's coming up after the
break make sure you're following us on
facebook
at facebook.com
pakman show
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want
from the foods i'm eating but that's why
athletic greens ag-1 is so great it's a
solution that gives you everything in
one scoop and you get 75 high quality
vitamins and minerals as well as
probiotics so it supports gut health it
is one of the great sort of add-ons to
having proper balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is down below